going red my name is pay of [ __ ] we're
stuck in this hellhole I know where to
go now we haven't checked out the
basement floor yet so we're gonna go
hello lady hey sexy lady we're gonna go
to the elevator up there in the right
corner it's going to be a quad to pickle
but I like pickles
actually I don't
that was easy enough eze it in here it's
in here
then we're finally gonna go to the
basement and get our sweet-ass hammered
thing because I remember we haven't been
in the basement yet it's our last cash
cow
I think Silent Hill is probably my
favorite game that I'm les playing right
now I didn't think I'd enjoy this game
so much but you're like what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen next
you just never know anyway let's go in
here this is wrong door
[ __ ] [ __ ] the amens in this place
hello don't start me please are there
this [ __ ] hammer time on these
[ __ ] hell yeah that's right I'm gonna
cook the [ __ ] up this thing is amazing
and by amazing I mean it [ __ ] kills
everyone
holy [ __ ] we gonna smack some [ __ ] up
smack my [ __ ] up sorry I come at me
Prez Oh stay the [ __ ] down you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you want some of this you want
some of this dear one hello lady hey
Jamie Oliver's nipples well you're not
dead yet period
Lamarr period remark ah [ __ ]
alright whatever oh I had the basement
storage key that's what I picked up all
right cool I'm sure nothing bad will be
down here
shotgun shells I need that what else
began and gun ammo I'll take that too
thank you very much game Oh charlie good
rather head to that game are you felling
Harry I haven't eaten in quite a while
you know is that a skid marks from the
key
oh it's been moved think we can push it
come on
[ __ ] the Amy's man all right what do we
got looks like a Holloway under the game
can't move it since the wines are grown
around
maybe we can put the fire ah fight goes
out right away when I light them and
then maybe put some alkaline it's total
out you pour alcohol alright that's
pretty genius peered strikes again right
there burn baby burn
oh I don't know if I want to go down
here
alright breasts let's do this oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh I'll out so [ __ ] creepy no no
no no all right Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam where's the other one
come here Oh fetch Mackin time fetch
noggin oh this thing is amazing
oh if you don't like it then you should
put your boot on it
you don't like it then you should've put
a boot on it hello lady just kidding
pilot hilari stop combo thank you
distracting bad as Harry keeps going
no I don't have a map for this place no
it's jammed it's gotta be another way
then the door here thank God
hello light ice lovely one down oh no
not teamwork don't you dare [ __ ] you
see whoa smack my [ __ ] up at super
effective health is fine
so anyone else here oh so many of them
uh-oh the videotape cool I know where we
can put this oh and your mama all right
oh thanks for waiting oh now you die
badass boots striking oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what is that oh shut up shut up shut up
what's going on what do you do when
don't like you Oh
[ __ ] am i what's this
I don't know Abed I should call them
Abed pretty sure the bed looks like
someone's been here
oh well there's been a couple monsters
hey man what is this a family photo
huh a lesson and a key I'll take that
aw come on this ambience examination
room key nice ass Harry
while this this is just wonderful
we gotta check all the rooms I'm not
going back here I only had a key
I ain't sexy lay down walk huh come on
that's my health so fine all right
[ __ ] there we go then
oh not this room not this or not this or
not just a room like this room my sister
what are you doing keep spawning alright
we've been in all the rim
I think at least I think we just need to
get out now
[ __ ] corridor of creepiness
oh we're back here let's check the map
examination room it's on the top floor
not the top floor but floor above me at
least
any ladies wanna [ __ ] then thinks a dead
end think so maybe I don't think that'll
work either honestly
one can only up
Oh EDA what's going on it's a guy
are you alright girl kind of hot
uh hello
someone's gonna get some finally someone
else who's okay yep who are you my
name's Lisa garland what's yours
Harry Harry Mason Harry tell me what's
happening here where is everybody
like to have no [ __ ] good I must have
gotten knocked out Oh sh ed by the 19-2
everyone was gone it's awful
yeah that's pretty awful so you don't
know anything either
great I just don't get it is she coming
with us I hope that it's like this is
all some kind of bad dream pretty much
yeah a living nightmare let me ask you
have you seen a little girl around here
short black hair seven years old seven
year old girl what she's your daughter
this adds to the question a seven year
old girl come on have a man have you
seen here I can't say that I have I was
unconscious all this time why did huh
I'm sorry
don't worry ah that's all right
we need to get out of here you don't
know anything about all that weird stuff
in the basement
No why is there something down there
how about hell all you don't know don't
you work here
we're under strict orders never to enter
the basement store so I really don't
know
Oh what did you say was down there you
tits
what damn darkness what's wrong aah
Harry Harry let me help you
Harry what's going on was I dreaming you
were too late no it's the evil wait it's
you sorry I took your sassy Dahlia
Gillespie
I don't need an introduction I want you
you won tell me everything you know
what's going on I love a darkness it was
dark the town is being devoured by
darkness strength must overcome petty
desire childish sleep talk what I knew
this day would come
okay what are you talking about I don't
understand a word of this I understand
everything
don't worry leave the evidence of your
eyes and never the other church in this
town that is your destination another
church this is beyond my abilities can
you move a little slower can stop it now
alright have you not seen the crest
marked on the ground all over town no I
mean yet so that's what I saw in the
school yard I how does it mean it is the
mark of Samael it sounds nice
don't let it be completed hey wait can't
you be a little more helpful well at
least we got a key antique shop key I
know where it is I know where it is
in such shop that we saw the girl go
through its just save here and then I
landed some Sunni oh [ __ ] love this
game it's getting really interesting I
don't know about your bread anyway
like a parrot and I Cipriano come up
right today and I see an X I'm shoulder
forever way kind of I'm rubbing my my
lobby breath I'm gonna go with my own
color scheme you never see the green
unibrow before well you ain't live man
you ain't live all right let's give him
a little moustache beautiful so be